[Applaudissements]
les monnaies à tous les publics à y
aller je vais demander à mon top alors
moi je démarre à vous de les supprimer
attention
[Musique]
[Rires]
franchement ce mec en or et il était
d'accord n'était pas choqué dabaaz
mainbourg vous faites m'en tombent
d'ailleurs j'ai une filiation
deuxième serait
coincée qui m'a poussé au départ dont le
quiz même très bien ce qu'est un bien
bel hommage qui commence très très bien
mais beaucoup vingt neuvième place fou
rire en parlant d'extraterrestres parce
que évidemment ça je reviendrais des
extraterrestres avec vous gilles parce
que je sais que vous y croyez dur comme
fer aux extraterrestres bah écoute et
justement les explications des frères
bogdanoff sur l'existence des
extraterrestres
c'était énorme et il disait qu'il venait
d'une autre planète et je les crois moi
igor et grichka la question c'est est ce
que je suis en a parmi nous mais oui
franchement les extraits balade dans la
vie de tous les jours dès maintenant non
mais franchement vous êtes sérieux l'opa
sérieux dans l'arrivée de la partie oui
alors ils savent pas il y a les extra
terrestres parmi nous
[Rires]
merci qui franchement mais il me faut et
je les adores mais nous après le garde
qu'est ce qu'il ya écrit
ggd
[Rires]
d'un côté
[Applaudissements]
il ya le plaisir de les voir
rester à nice et qui se mord revers ils
sont morts de rire le même de leurs
vannes tout en étant extrêmement sérieux
parce qu'ils croyaient réellement en
l'existence de présence comme vous
d'ailleurs gilles oui mais ce qu'est ce
qui est incroyable c'est leur
autodérision avec ce côté savant mais
réelle ce sont de grands jeux par leur
présence et soupe de grands savants des
chercheurs est toujours en train
d'expérimenter de savoir ce qui va se
passer et pour les extraterrestres
c'était une ouverture d'esprit complet
il avait l'esprit parfaitement ouvert
s'ils acceptaient tous vous parlez de
grandes études effectivement igor était
titulaire d'un diplôme d'études
approfondies un dea en sémiologie et un
doctorat en physique théorique et
grichka il était diplômé de l'institut
d'études politiques de paris sciences po
est titulaire d'un doctorat en
mathématiques c'était d'être on sait
jamais il n'y a pas de doctorat en
mathématiques
[Rires]
en
mètres c'était roland barthes pour la
reprise pour la discussion est là enfin
une façon de s'exprimer qui était
remarquable et leur grand maître c'est
tannant sémiologue roland barthes et
c'était fans lors la mairie magali on
appellerait j'avais pas compris les
intitulés des études qu'ils ont fait
[Rires]
à
l'aveuglé que l'on dise n'importe quoi
sur eux et ils entretenaient d'ailleurs
ce mystère hier x e même quand on leur
disait extraterrestre vu l'auto dérision
qu'ils avaient il aimait bien qu'on
raconte la perte au coach qu'il avait
très envie d'ailleurs pour les prennent
pour
est d'ailleurs bon bah vous savez qu'il
venait régulièrement tous les deux sur
les plateaux de télévision et notamment
sur tpm parce que encore une fois on
leur dit c'est la famille s'était il
venait réguler sa moi ça fait dix ans de
tpm p il était tout le temps là vraiment
et il venait pour réaliser des
expériences scientifiques pour
vulgariser oui et notamment avec
certains chroniqueurs cette fois c'était
avec thierry moreau comme comme cobayes
thierry qu'ils portaient vous savez ce
qu'on appelle les exosquelettes il
permet de décupler votre force ils ont
et pierre- y affrontaient cyril dans
différentes épreuves regarder
alors c'est là sa kangoo les visas c'est
un exosquelette qui permet ouais 2 x 15
la force musculaire par 15 la force
musculaire 15e tir est mort alors est ce
qu'on peut faire un test en fait un test
alors savourer et chez les poids de 6 kg
d'accord alors il s'est laissé par
exemple de le tenir de tenir comme ça
est ce vrai nom est distraite par
l'exosquelette
oui oui toi tu veux mettre ton manteau
en se
donnant le fait que deux choses beaucoup
plus puisque vrai qu'on va essayer grâce
à cet exosquelette de voir ce que fera
qu'assez sept plans d'accord d'abord toi
tu essayes donc moi je vais essayer d'en
moyenne je vais pas là
non
[Applaudissements]
et c'est une loi
pour tous et mine de rien on se marrait
beaucoup info europe1 net parce qu'avec
igor et grichka on se marrait tout le
temps mais on apprenait des choses on
apprenait des trucs et je crois vous
benjamin vous étiez fan de temps et que
j'adorais toute première énorme qui les
a révélés au grand public et que vous
fassiez des experts alors je refais
techniques sont que des bêtises parce
que il avait montré comment en fait
l'hélicoptère pouvait s'élever du sol et
il expliqué qu'ils avaient une bonne
dose on pouvait créer son hélicoptère
donc j'étais la campagne il y avait des
croix nazies et je n'ai pas baissé
depuis ton arrivée il y avait une
tondeuse donc j'ai démonté datant deux
géants de jouer bonne idée des pillages
et enlever les lames qui sont qui sont
là pour retour le gazon et j'ai pris
deux grands drames des grands drames que
j'ai que j'ai installé cru que j'évite
sais j'ai retourné de moteurs ge
l'émission montre ici qu'avec le plus
c'est rémy de tiges pour pour pour
manoeuvrer les pales et j'ai dit je
mettre en route et n'était pas loin
d'une grande verrière celle de bagram et
on le mettait ses fleurs résolument vers
la 18ème siècle magnifique et donc j'ai
mis en route le sauf que j'avais mal
installés les rames à la main qui ont
fini dans la verrière
[Rires]
je n'étais pas au niveau de tout le
monde je n'ai pas tout compris ce
principe de nuit kopter est bien
d'accord